hey this is really really funny
karl rove wrote an op-ed in the washing
in the wall street journal
called
where do trump's donations go and it's a
very good question karl rove points out
he can't spend his packs millions on
2024 because he's not running he's not
using m yet he's not using the money
really to support midterm candidates
based on the spending disclosures that
we've seen
and i will add to that that yesterday we
found out that the republican national
committee is paying donald trump's legal
bills so what the hell is trump spending
the money on and karl rove who is a
anti-trump republican strategist says
what will donald trump do with his
campaign cash trump controls four packs
save america
make america great again again
trump make america great again and make
america great again action the pax cash
on hand as of june 30th came to 103
million 10 million 7.3 million and 700 k
that puts 121 million dollars at trump's
disposal
um small donors were pummeled with
requests for trump's causes in a 24-hour
stretch this week writes karl rove i
received 25 fundraising pleas from the
trump world beseeching me to help
america for the from the democrats save
america for the democrats in exchange
for donations i was offered a trump card
a blue one then a gold one then a
t-shirt then wine glasses then my name
on the donor wall and all these
different things and money is flowing
into trump's various packs but what is
he going to do with the money
karl rove writes one option is convert
the money to a presidential campaign
according to federal election lawyers
that's one possibility
what can trump use the cash for now well
he can support other candidates but he's
not really doing that
um he could do independent expenditures
on behalf of candidates buying ads and
this sort of thing for other candidates
but trump hasn't done much of that
either
um what exactly is going to happen with
this money and karl rove writes if trump
doesn't start deploying these funds to
help the candidates he's backing donors
might not keep giving now there i
disagree with karl rove there is a cult
of personality around donald trump where
he could even admit i'm using the money
to hire my family
and refurbish my private jet and
whatever
and the vast majority of his followers
would say
all right i mean sounds like he needs
the private jet and his family are some
of the smartest people so it makes sense
to give them the cult actually wouldn't
really care
but it is an extraordinarily
consistent question that we have because
in the immediate aftermath of the 2020
election remember when trump lost but
said we're going to raise money and
we're going to audit this and we're
going to recount that and we're going to
do all these different things and they
didn't do it in the fine print it said
up to 50 or in some cases more of your
donation can be used to pay off campaign
debt
and so it's almost certainly some kind
of grift we just don't know what it is
yet now there's another kind of just
bigger picture thing
is trump
going to try to use the money to support
other candidates but not just out of the
goodness of his heart
conditionally in exchange for
favors
support in 24 whatever that's the other
idea which is trump will ultimately
relent and as we get closer to the
november midterms now we're only uh just
a a you know a little bit over three
months away
trump will start to deploy the money for
the people that he's supporting but in
exchange for vows of uh loyalty going
into 2024. let me know your thoughts
what do you think trump's raising the
money for what do you think he's going
to use the money for but a great
question from karl rove where are the
donations actually going
make sure that you are following me on
twitter at deepakman let me know where
do you think the donations are going and
of course make sure to sign up at
joinpakman.com the program is viewer
supported and i would love to have your
support we're going to take a quick
break it is a uh packed friday show
chock full
of content
as the kids these days say
when i'm looking for a good documentary
i'll sometimes scroll around on your
average streaming services and they're
okay but i almost always end up on an
app called curiositystream our sponsor
curiosity stream is the king of
documentaries they have only
documentaries i recently watched insect
apocalypse it is horrifying what's going
on with the bees extremely disturbing
but the documentary insect apocalypse is
fascinating and i can't recommend it
more highly there's a curiosity stream
app for all of your devices curiosity
stream is always adding new titles they
have a ton of awesome original content
they have the big award-winning
documentaries by the filmmakers we all
know they also have smaller independent
documentaries that are often just as
good on every topic under the sun and
the best part about curiosity stream is
how affordable it is you can get full
access for 14.99 a year not a month a
year that's a buck 25 a month when you
go to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is in the description